y hablamos de las elecciones
legislativas en irak que estuvieron
marcadas por la baja participación según
la comisión electoral de ese país solo
acudieron a las urnas el 41% de las
personas habilitadas para poder votar
este 41% representa poco más de 9
millones de iraquíes de un total de 25
millones con derecho a este voto las
provincias que registraron una menor
participación fueron las dos distritos
electorales de bagdad la baja
participación era una de las principales
preocupaciones de las autoridades y
partidos iraquíes que urgieron a la
ciudadanía a acudir a las urnas para así
dar credibilidad a estas elecciones
convocadas en respuesta a la oleada de
protestas que sacudirá que en octubre de
2019 y que terminaron con la dimisión
del anterior gobierno para ello entonces
ahora si le doy la bienvenida a
margarida cadavid de jazz
internacionalista de la universidad del
rosario con posgrado en derechos humanos
y defensa ante del sistema internacional
de protecciones a ciertos políticos
internacionales también la editora de
noticias de aceite frase en el cairo en
egipto y experto en temas de medio
oriente gracias margarita por estar con
nosotros en directo américa muy buen día
porque ésta a participar de esta baja
participación en las elecciones y forme
los jóvenes que protestaron en las
calles para pedir estas elecciones
anticipadas
muchas gracias a ustedes por la
invitación y buenos días también pues
mira básicamente las elecciones como tú
lo dices anticipadas fueron promovidas
por las protestas por la serie de
protestas que se habían presentado
frente a dos cosas principalmente la
corrupción del país y que el país ha
estado en manos de los mismos desde hace
varios años entonces se hizo un llamado
precisamente y es lo que más o menos se
tiene conocimiento en este momento un
llamado a boicotear las elecciones
porque para las personas en este momento
inclusive para esos jóvenes que salieron
a protestar a pesar de que la nueva ley
electoral permite la inclusión de una
cantidad de candidatos independientes
ellos sienten que básicamente no va a
cambiar nada que la situación va a
seguir siendo exactamente la misma
entonces hubo como dos movimientos
también uno que fue el llamado al boicot
un llamado al boicot que viene desde los
mismos protestantes desde las mismas
personas que protestaron en el 2019 y el
líder religioso
el gran ayatolá alí sistaní que pidió
que por favor la gente saliera de manera
masiva
sin embargo como vimos esta ha sido una
de las votaciones más bajas lo que
demuestra también que se está empezando
a generar esa apatía política en irak y
ese sentimiento entre la población
especialmente los más jóvenes de que
nada va a cambiar y pues el resultado
volverá a ser un parlamento bastante
bastante fragmentado hablamos entonces
de uno de los protagonistas en la
política ahora actual en irak y los
jóvenes no que fue también el motor de
estas elecciones anticipadas porque este
boicot entonces para ellos digamos o
cuál podría ser la salida política que
ellos quieren si no es por la vía
electoral que pudieran hacer ellos para
poder cambiar la actualidad política de
su país
básicamente el problema cuál es el
problema es que los principales partidos
los dos principales partidos en este
momento y el poder está en manos de los
chiítas entonces el que hayan entrado
una cantidad de candidatos
independientes no mejora la situación
porque entonces todos estos votos quedan
completamente atomizados tenemos un
partido que sea el de matar
sada o sad arista que es un partido
chiíta que se opone a cualquier
intervención extranjera de cualquier
venga de donde venga inclusivas y
haciendo chiítas también se oponen a la
intervención extranjera iraní y tenemos
otro partido que es el de jade al mar y
que era un grupo paramilitar que
contribuyó muchísimo y ayudó muchísimo
en la lucha contra isis y este partido
si se abre mucho a lo que es la
intervención extranjera porque de hecho
muchos de sus militantes en su momento
eran estaban digamos relacionados
vinculados con irá entonces hay un grupo
dentro del país que básicamente quiere
que irán e irak perdón salga adelante
que irak tenga una nueva oportunidad con
unas elecciones digamos donde haya
posibilidades de acceso a esos a esos
escaños que tienen y donde además se le
quite a esta élite que es la que ha
venido gobernando el poder de las manos
sin embargo en las actuales
circunstancias y sentimiento de la
población es que esto no es posible
entre otras por la injerencia extranjera
el actual digamos el actual primer
ministro ha logrado equilibrar muy bien
y ese es una de las cosas a tener en
cuenta con lo que va a pasar a partir de
ahora porque el primer ministro saldrá
de él el grupo mayoritario en el
parlamento del partido mayoritario en el
parlamento este personaje ha logrado
verdaderamente equilibrar los intereses
de los eeuu y también los intereses de
irán y ha sabido jugar muy bien este
juego sin embargo vamos a ver qué va a
pasar entonces por eso por esa razón por
ese sentimiento de que a través de las
elecciones a pesar de que ellos generan
este cambio a pesar de que ellos generan
estas elecciones anticipadas pues es una
constante en este tipo de movimiento se
genera toda la situación pero no tienen
verdaderamente un partido que los
represente y que unifique y que analice
todas esas nuevas aspiraciones pensaría
yo que ese es una de las principales
problemáticas en este momento ahora
margarito haciendo así las cosas además
están complicadas cuál va a ser la
legitimidad del próximo gobierno y a lo
mejor como podría estar conformado no
pues esa es una de las cosas que está
digamos en juego porque estamos hablando
de que 25 millones de personas podían
votar en estas elecciones de esos 25
millones de personas
creo que el conteo en este momento va
que han votado el 19 por ciento es decir
menos de la mitad entonces ahí ya habría
que tomar una decisión de acuerdo
digamos al sistema si se volvería a
convocar elecciones porque evidentemente
lo que estamos viendo aquí es que
responde un poco también tu pregunta el
boicot de los de quienes protestaron en
octubre verdaderamente funcionó porque
la gente no se acercó a votar no se
acercó a las urnas y digamos que no es
un tema de seguridad no es un tema de
que no haya sido posible desplazamiento
es porque ha hecho se desplegaron van
varias varias mesas de votación para que
la gente pudiera asistir entonces esa es
la gran el gran cuestionamiento que
queda con una votación
de este calibre que tan legítimo puede
ser el gobierno que salga de esta de
esta elección si no vamos a volver a
presenciar pues una serie de protestas y
levantamientos pidiendo que se echen
para atrás se reversión o se repitan
estas elecciones y eso hizo quiero
preguntar entonces margarida a grandes
rasgos cómo se puede leer esta elección
no también analizando un poco
socialmente irak como llegaron ellos
hasta aquí pues evidentemente estábamos
hablando también las protestas de los
jóvenes en el 2019 pero también entonces
que otros factores condujeron a irak
donde esta obra y pues la gran lección
no que deja estas elecciones para el
gobierno
entonces que irak ha presentado digamos
varias crisis a lo largo de estos
últimos años desde el 2003 que fue la
caída del gobierno de saddam hussein a
la actualidad hemos tenido varios
procesos simultáneos en irak uno de esos
pues tuvo que ver con lo que sucedió en
mosúl con los kurdos la declaración de
querer un estado independiente del
pueblo kurdo tuvieron que estamos en un
sistema donde tenemos a un primer
ministro que es chiíta donde tenemos a
un presidente vocero de los kurdos y a
un líder del parlamento que sunita
entonces seguimos viendo un país que
está fragmentado en términos religiosos
cada uno de estos grupos tienen sus
propios digamos sus propios intereses
fuera de eso tenemos unos niveles de
violencia que se incrementaron con la
presencia de isis entonces creo que en
esos momentos el país estaba completo
con el tema de isis el país estaba
abocado a luchar a la lucha contra isis
y luego nos queda abierto todo este
espacio donde ya no está y si es
presente pero hay una de irán importante
y donde empezamos a ver ya una lucha una
verdadera lucha política dentro de la
arena política iraní irak y perdón
entonces en ese sentido lo que estamos
viendo es que llega en un momento donde
la gente siente que desde desde el 2003
a hoy nada ha cambiado que el poder
sigue en manos de las mismas élites y
que hay un porcentaje amplio la
población que está por fuera de la toma
de decisiones y los niveles de
corrupción son otra de las cosas que ha
agotado a la población en irá en irak